j'avais 18 ans quand je me suis marié
mais ce n'était pas par amour votre mari
est un saint et nous devons tous le
chérir pour le salut de la russie
tu connais le comprendre ce qui s'était
belle et riche officier de cavalerie
danser avec moi
je dois te mettre en garde le mettre en
garde
tu pourrais par son insouciance est
exposé aux commérages
cela doit cesser si vous avez un peu d
estime pour moi laissez moi en paix je
ne vois aucune paix pour nous
seulement le malheur ou le plus grand
bonheur nous sommes unis par dieu
qu'est-il arrivé je suis prise dans la
tourmente
je commettrais empêcher si je déteste
tout détruire
le désir charnel comme fin en soi nous
détournent de ce qui est sacré
anna n'a commis aucun crime mais elle
s'est moquée des convenances cycle pour
moi vous annoncer à ma vie elle sera
déshonoré
tu es une femme indigne
crois tu vraiment que je vais te laisser
mon fils
je t'aime pourquoi l'amour ne s'explique
pas